[Music]
let's take a call that's not so close to
home like right in the booth yeah that'd
be great it was a little uh little too
close for me go with the ychy on that
one let's go out to Omaha and talk to
Jeff hey Jeff what's up man hey not much
just uh well took your anxiety test and
well I'm a little worried because I
scored red in every category that there
was
retro all right so walk me through it
man well I I don't even know where to
start because yeah I think I scored a
yellow and belief but that's like I
think that's more Church related or
religious or I read it said worshiping
stuff and I don't think I really worship
anything you know okay well I guess
besides God but yeah okay so backing out
you have a lot of red and a yellow did
that ring true to you or did you think
well maybe the quiz is broken well I'm
thinking maybe I just think it's my
normal where other people would see it
would be a
red you don't get an exemption on
Humanity yeah that's what I'm calling
you um what's going what's going on in
your life oh I could probably tell you
20 different things tell all 20 of them
rip them off let's go a little over
exagger but I got the well we got four
kids one's four or no one yeah one's
four one's two one is one and we got one
in the oven yet at 22 or 23
weeks and then my wife moved her friend
in with us and we just have this little
modular 800 foot home to help with
bills and I started a new job path of
owning my own Auto Repair business that
just kicked off last week so a little
bit of everything I
guess so I don't know how to say this
nicely
your body is sounds like it is working
about
perfectly yeah well it's been this way
before all all this new stuff just
happened the past couple weeks but yeah
it I probably would have scored the same
before that and it would have been a
different version of the same chaos
Fair
yeah where did you learn to live in
chaos man this is an acquired
taste well oh I guess my family grew up
a little bit different than my wife's
where her family's all kind of touchy
feely and talk everything and my
family's kind of like keep to yourself
and I don't think I've ever hugged my
dad before Oh man but it's like it's a
normal thing like I don't feel bad about
it or anything I know dude but the the
title of Bessel KK's book Vander KK's
book is the body keeps the score whether
you want to keep it or not yeah right
and that's why I'm always like with my
kids um we have the three girls that are
the oldest which that's probably a a
whole headache there but I'm always like
I give them hugs and everything they
need so I know because when you have
parents like that you know you don't
that's not the way you want to raise
them who's giving Jeff what Jeff
needs um I I'm just trying to take care
of everyone I kind of like to put myself
last I know and your body is telling you
that it's about to
quit
it's about to
yeah why with three teeny tiny ones and
then a fourth one on the way did you
decide to open up your own mechanic
shop
well I'm really not sure it's my
understanding is mechanic shops take
several years to become profitable right
um not so much because I started out on
the farm we own so we're not making
payments and uh I'm mobile so like I
don't really have a lot of overhead okay
I have a I have a buddy that runs a
six-figure Mobile Oil Change business so
I I've seen that done up close and it's
pretty amazing so cool but you still
have to build a book of
business yeah which that's why we moved
back to my uh Hometown where I grew up
on the farm where I I'm local I know
people in the area and I've already had
quite a bit of business but also your
body may have put some GPS pins in
living local and living back on the farm
it remembers life wasn't so great
sometimes
Fair yeah but we lived in uh in Omaha
inside the ca limits and it that
stresses me out like crazy just being
packed full with everyone and I like out
in the open okay wh why in the world is
this a good time for a
roommate uh well it's it was hard it was
a hard decision because it's my wife's
best friend she's a single mom and she's
like she's really struggling and I think
she sees it as like her own like it's
her way I don't know like it's something
with she said she prayed on it and she
said that she needs to be there for her
and help her
and I'm not really I like her decide on
it mostly because you know she's the one
in the house you
know prob it sounds B but she's like the
one that has the deal with it I guess
more where I'm you know I'm out working
more yeah that's a that's a cursory
glance at it you're right but you're the
one that has to come
home to a devastated and exhausting
pregnant
wife and a four-year-old and a
2-year-old and a
one-year-old and somebody else's kid how
many kids does she have the roomate well
she's got she's got two but they're one
you know they're kind of they go to
their dads and stuff so it's kind of off
and
on in an 800 square foot house yeah uh
because we moved it here in hopes that
we were going to start building our
house here in a in a year or two there's
no chance you can do that yeah it's
starting to seem more like that
yeah so
here's here's where I think you should
start okay
that wheel that six daily choices wheel
is supposed to be a road map and when
all seven are
red I want you to look and say okay
what's the easiest entry point for me
here and I know you have a lot of
obligations but what you're telling me
is to use a farm analogy I have a ton of
hey that's got to get bailed out
there and your dad is telling you I I
know but you got to change the oil and
put gas in the tractor and you're saying
I don't have time for that I got to bail
the
hay and you know as well as I do that
six stripes in the field that tractor is
going to park itself and it's going to
Brick itself right yeah so the best
thing to do to get all that hay bailed
is to stop and take care of that
tractor and continue to take care of
that tractor while you're bailing the
hay Fair
fa okay you're no better than a tractor
right now you actually are way better
than a tractor but the analogy works
so I want you just to look at that thing
and
pick all you don't get a pass on all six
of them dude I went down the nerd
research with the scientist I went back
to old religious Traditions not just
Christian but all I mean dude you don't
get a pass on it so if you don't have
one or two men in your life that you go
regularly hang out
with your body knows oh all of this is
on you all of it if your business fails
if um your wife and your four kids plus
the single mom and her two kids if one
thing goes sideways everybody's
out your body knows that and it would be
failing you with that kind of stress to
let you sleep all
night it would be failing you if the
moment you open your eyes it didn't just
flood the system with cortisol because
it is at
War and so you have to do the hard work
you move back to your hometown you got
to find one or two men that you go out
once a week and just go hang out with
and you're going to think I don't have
time for that and I'm telling you that
your body doesn't have time for you not
to and then we're just going to go
around the go around when's the last
time you went to a doctor and got a
checkup um probably few years yeah it's
time go get some blood work
done go have your doctor check your um
uh blood pressure and your give you a
blood
test well blood pressure I have the oh
the hospital reaction where my blood
pressure is fine at home then if I'm in
a doctor that stresses me out so it goes
High okay don't solve that at home
inside of your 800 foot trailer tell
your doctor that they're not dumb
despite what some people on YouTube
think okay and then we're just going to
go around the go around the
list but I want you to decide what about
choosing Freedom how much money do y'all
owe you have any debt yeah we got yeah
we got debt that's that's another reason
why I wanted to start this new career
because more uh better money coming in
is that actual better better money is it
real yeah okay yeah actually the few
weeks have been going it's been yeah a
lot better okay are you is that include
putting 25% aside or 30% aside because
you're going have to pay small business
tax um yeah that's still putting yeah
after all of our taxes and deductions
and everything that's still coming out
ahead okay um it might be for a season
you got to do that and then in the
evenings you got to drive Uber deliver
pizzas I don't know what you can do out
in the country out there but you might
have to work for a season extra hard
yeah well been doing a side gig also
besides Auto Repair great but I want you
and your wife to do that with a plan
after this call is over I'm going to
send you two copies of the book and I'm
going to S send you Financial Peace
University and I'm going to send you
every dollar app for a year okay okay
that's going to be a road map across a
bunch of different fronts but listen if
you owe somebody money if your
Calendar's bananas if your house is so
chaotic with six kids under the age of
four plus two moms trying to figure out
what dude of course your body is s
singing the alarms off the wall just
banging banging banging banging the
alarms of course if you called like no
dude everything's great I'm sleeping
like a baby I would tell you go to the
doctor now something's not right right
that is the one thing I do get is eight
hours of sleep at night I will say
that I would I I would love for you to
track that
sleep I bet it is very thin either that
or your body has figured out the magic
way to just go into a black hole as
self-preservation all that to say is
this find one Avenue and go down that
rabbit hole and I want you and your wife
to sit down and be honest with the first
step choosing
reality yes that single mom friend of
hers needs help and support and
love but three little ones plus a brand
new business plus a fourth baby on the
way may have may not be the moment for
youall I don't know how you'll have
enough space in this little place like
just literal physical
space and so I want you to choose
reality and to begin to go down and say
okay where can we choose peace over
chaos
exercise health and healing
relationships y'all can't have any body
over you got too much chaos
right yeah
yeah and you're going to have to decide
to choose peace in this season if you
don't then I mean it's a choice you're
making but don't blame the anxiety don't
blame the anxiety
test blame the world you and your wife
have
created and I say blame the world like
it's not a bad thing it's just a very
very very chaotic
life you're asking your body to do
something it wasn't designed to do which
is everything all at once all at the
same time while being indebted while
having no exit strategy while having we
hope to build in two years you don't
have a road map you don't even have a
financial map to get there or a business
plan or I need to be making this much
money by this date and I'm going to
check in with these two guys once a week
just to make sure I'm on track you don't
have any of that stuff your body is
screaming at you so hang on the line
send you two copies of building a
non-anxious life I'm going to give you
the road map for the finances allow you
and your wife to get connected yall
going to have to decide hey if we're
going to do all this stuff we have to
choose peace over
chaos wherever we
can it's G to be chaotic with four
little ones it's going to be chaotic
starting a new job in a new town in a
new business in an 800 foot
trailer what chaotic moments outside of
those two things can we begin to shed so
that we don't all implode because as I
said at the beginning of this call that
tractor is about to stop in the middle
of the field and then everybody's
done you are worth being
well